great thank you very much Gary so as you
can see that obviously the topic of this
talk is going to be related to the
previous talk and it's actually great to
be talking out tomorrow because their
paper I read I said when the first
reading the diffusion weightless paper
back in maybe 2007 or 2008 and how
excited i got about it and some of the
ideas that led to this work come
directly from trying to make that sense
of that paper and the trying to put it
to work and figuring out the possible
alternative approaches it's important
that was really the first as far as i
can tell it was the first paper which
put these classical ideas of mulch
resolution analysis in the discrete
setting you know mathematically last
night to be rigorous and been well
justified manner it's also for the same
reason it slightly intimidating to be
talking about tomorrow especially since
Ronnie Clayton I've been looking at this
sort of stuff for about 30 years whereas
I've been looking at it for more like
three so Maru please interrupt mr. that
as you're going in to be your job at the
appropriate moments it's important to
say that this work is joined with with
two students natalina ten Ava who is at
uchicago and she's my student and
because guard who was at the TT either
to you to Institute in Chicago and I was
at MIT so all the credit she shared
between the three of us so this workshop
when this whole program will is about
spectral graph theory and we're talking
about something which is still related
to graphs and in form of harmonic
analysis but in some says it's in
contrast to the classic or spectral
approach this classical special approach
says that you start with something like
the graph laplacian and you diagonalize
it right so you start with this linear
algebra operation of diagonalizing the
very laplacian looking at its spectral
decomposition and then if you have
functions on the graph then you expand
your function in a basis in the basis
formed by these by these eigenvectors
okay so this this whole approach has a
rich red arrow reaches very successful
history in theoretical computer science
and learning problems also used for
dimensional reduction
some of the proponents of this are
sitting right in the audience I do need
to don't need to proselytize event about
the bat-spectrograph 3 to this crowd in
particular it has been hugely successful
and also and also conceptually extremely
important in trying to in learning how
to handle drafts and find their
structures the one thing to notice about
this spectral approach is that in some
ways it is the analog of Fourier
analysis right because what does free
analysis do if you are a physicist and
you think of foreigners for example and
you see the connections to the to the
momentum operator and quantum mechanics
or if you just look at the matrix of the
Fourier transform that is actually made
up of the eigenvectors of a given
operator right so this is very similar
to that sort of approach you have an
operator govern describing the structure
of your space your graph in this minus
contacts and you look at its
eigenvectors and then you express
everything else in terms of bad those
eigenvectors okay so there are very many
parallels between for analysis theory or
fully analysis and spectral graph theory
in some sense is just for analysis on
graphs so it straighter shares all the
strength of Fourier analysis the
beautiful theory but also in chairs some
of the shows some of the computational
difficulties associated food for a type
approaches in particular we I mean when
we teach spectrograph 30 students we
always say how the important thing is
that the eigen that is at different
eigenvalues separate the local versus
the global structure on the graph right
that's that's the whole point Thank that
Lulu I can value eigen Frank back to
somehow capture the global surf and
high-frequency eigenvectors capture the
local stuff but then why is it but even
the high-frequency eigenvectors have
global support they spread over the
entire graph right they're dense and
their support covers the entire graph so
from a computational problem point of
view especially when you start looking
at large matrices obviously this is
problematic why should I have to compute
these massive eigenvectors fine
my relationship to two morrow and some
social network why do I need to worry
about how we're both related to somebody
in Mongolia right and and in our world
it usually happens that when something
computationally becomes becomes
problematic that's often an indication
that conceptually there is also some
kind of gap there right so that that's a
sign of something really going on it's
captured the spectral approach certainly
captures the structure of the grab but
it catches in a particular way and maybe
that's not the optimal especially when
you when you're dealing with really
massive graphs which have intricate
maybe hierarchical structure that you
want to boot the scribe and exploit okay
so so although the Fourier approach
certainly separates different scales
because the different eigen vectors
correspond to different kind of
frequency waves on the on the graph
essentially it's still a very flat thing
you have these five actors which spread
it over the entire graph and nothing and
there's new there any of the notions of
localization and many of the
combinatorial aspects of the underlying
graph are somehow lost in in in in in
the process okay in contrast
multiresolution analysis so this is
multi lucien analysis in general this is
just a just a very simple orthogonal
wavelet transform so mantras analysis X
decomposes functions in terms of
wavelets where the wavelets are at
specific scales so these are the
wavelets these are my basis functions
now and there's explicitly a scale
associated to each wavelet so at each
scale al you have a certain number of
wavelets which the capture structure at
that particular scale okay so this kind
of decomposition makes this
multi-resolution nature of the analysis
very transparent you really do have
wavelets which correspond to the small
scales on the mediums case on the large
scales and their support reflects this
fact so the high frequency wavelength
which capture local behavior of your
function really only have small support
they only diskant
they only localize to small parts of
your space or your graph whatever domain
you are working on okay so this was a
major major trend in applied mathematics
of moving kind of moving from the
Fourier picture to the mod resolution
picture in the last 20 or 25 years of
the of the previous century okay so at a
slightly more abstract level so this is
this is moment people talk about waiters
they usually think about some things
like the wavelets on the real line or
maybe wavelets on euclidean space but
there is something more abstract going
on in the background of course and the
way to think of much resolution analysis
with this of and wavelet transforms it
is the sequential process this iterative
process of taking your entire space of
functions on your space which in our
case is going to be the graph so I use L
2 of X here that really depends on the
context but this a letter to say LM XO
so some appropriate space of functions
on the graph and then doing this
repeated splitting of taking dive the
high frequency parts so forming a basis
for the high frequency parts of my space
and then kind of throwing that out
saying that this part of the space
captures what happens at this level of
resolution and I said that size that
apart and set this aside and what
remains so we have this direct some of
the analysis space and and wavelet space
so what remains I again split of the
high frequency kman part of and so on so
it's a repeated process of always taking
the high frequency parts and kind of
setting them aside as you go through
this process and actually this is what
how fast wavelet transform actually work
they explicitly go through the sequence
of transformations you are going to be
literally kind of peeling away the parts
of your function at different levels of
resolution until at the end you have
something which is the most global
smoothest level and that's what's
captured by the final scaling functions
these Phi L functions okay
so this is underlying an abstract
picture behind multiresolution analysis
so the question is how do you define
smoothness in the first place okay and
in harmonic analysis in general this is
just defined by an appropriate self
adjoint operator right so Mauro's
approach was all motivated by diffusion
which is not a surprise because that's
the that's the most natural notion of
smoothing on anything rent so it's a
smoothing under on the Euclidean space
or a smoothing on graphs a solution of
Gaussian or is not Gaussian it's some
sort of diffusion it's a satisfies
attractive in various properties and
then you kind of bootstrap from that so
you define the space again this is a
public with publicist or publish you
define the space in terms of this
operator and then you can replace
questions about the geometry of the
space with questions about the operator
itself and as you go through this
process I mean your spaces get smaller
and smaller right because you keep
putting stuff aside so you're
restricting your operator into smaller
and smaller sub spaces so you're also
compressing the operator at the very
same time okay so ought to proselytize
slightly more why is this good and why
do you do I feel that this is the sort
of thing that really should make sense
on graphs but real graphs are exactly
exactly this sort of multiple what I
would expect them to have its own
exactly the sort of multiresolution
structure right so people are interested
in social networks and information
networks and so on and interested in
communities within those networks well
you would expect communities to appear
at different scales smaller communities
like people in this room and we are
selected in multiple ways and then we
from bigger communities based on we're
all scientists or computer scientists my
applied mathematicians and so on and
larger communities and so on so this
kind of hierarchy of different scales is
what we kind of feel it should be there
in
in real-world graphs and which should be
one of the organizing principles one of
the ways in which we can capture in the
structure of the graph and exploit but
at the same time it's something that is
not necessary trivial to peel off and
the other thing about it is that it so
so one expects this structure of
communities and meta communities and
mathematica communications and so on but
in real settings it might not be just
you know if it was just one hierarchy
like that we would run by Rho clustering
at the end of the that would be the end
of the story but you know if we look at
a social network for example then people
cluster based on their profession or
their jobs right well we also cluster
based on where they are from and their
political predilections and so on so
they're really multiple hierarchies
which somehow interact and that's what
makes makes the problem of of exploring
this sort of structure challenging and
it's also what makes Jairo festering
sometimes a risky process because higher
guitar string can be unstable so it
small changes McGrath can really two
totally different clusterings and if you
have interacting system hierarchies
that's a glassy sort of sort of
situation which might arise okay so
finally this sort of multiresolution
analysis is not just a way of modeling
the graph but as mal room stressed
several times in his lecture it's also a
way of setting up the right basis for
doing something on the graph for example
learning on the graph for example if you
want to learn some function on the graph
like in machine learning we try to do
all the time and you want to use a
sparse estimate or something lasso like
then we want the appropriate basis and
and this is a multiresolution basis
might is it as an attractive proposition
from that point of view so it's both the
way of modeling the graph and modeling
functions or stuff happening on the
graphs and finally it's also potentially
a way of coming up with fast
computational methods which exactly
exploit this hierarchical structure
support them
okay so at the high level harmonic
analysis is all about this kind of
correspondence that if you are to study
a space that the further the study of a
space and the sunny of the son of the
structure of functions on that space are
two things that are closely
interconnected and and it can go both
ways so really understanding what your
space is about so really understanding
your graph helps you figure out how to
say learn functions on the graph at the
same time understanding the structure of
space on the structure of the space of
functions on the graph maybe that's the
way to understand what's really going on
in the graph itself this is the hearing
the shine shape of a belt type of
problem if you wish yeah so the nice
thing about about the fact that that the
Maori spoke just before me that I can
quote him from his papers and I mean
isn't you can't really put it any better
than this saying that the interplay
between the geometry of sets function
spaces on sets and operators on sets is
a classical theme in harmonic analysis
so this is a bug that you only get once
once you once you really absorb this
then it's going to be with you and this
is very much the spirit of the last talk
and the present talk so the question is
then how do you do this so how do you
actually define appropriate
multiresolution on a graph and this has
been a little this has become somewhat
of a somewhat of a fashionable area but
there were precursors of course in graph
compression and so on but I think a
major momentum actually came from from
Ronnie's and Mouser man numerous paper
and then there were several other
approaches which are mostly
complementary so tree lights for example
which I will be referring to several
times in the store spectrograph wavelets
which murrells already mentioned in this
comparison slide the tree wavelets of
garnish mandarins Kaufman and finally I
think that our approach based on
moderation fact matrix factorizations is
the latest addition to this to this list
so the key thing here is that I think
what we're really adding to this
that we make this very strong connection
to the problem of multiresolution and
graphs to factorizing matrices saying
that these two problems are again
essentially the same thing okay so
recently that an overview paper has come
out by Schumann and others including
Vander grains summarizing this whole
area one interesting one commonality
between these different approaches is
that I think the majority of people
whose names mentioned on this slide are
either a TL or were graduate students at
year or our work postdocs idea but I was
never ready to help yeah so so to try
and try and formalize this problem and
figure out how to put wavelets on graphs
let's go back to the foundations of
modern solution rasa so what is multi
solution analysis really about so the
most classical setting is of course
multi-resolution on the real line and it
was mala who formalized axiomatically
but the in that case these the sequence
of East bases and W spaces is supposed
to satisfy so in the most classical
sense in the canonical case to put an
orthogonal multiresolution on the real
line you set up a sequence of a nested
sequence of these these spaces in such a
way and that it's an invalid sequence so
their intersection is the M is just the
0 function if their union is essentially
the whole LTR so it's dancing l to r and
then how the crucial question is each of
the spaces is shifting variant so by
integer shifts you stay inside the space
and you can already see the beginnings
of a multiresolution structure because
the amount that you shift with so the
strike depends on which space you're in
so as L increases then the steps that
then the venue then the shift step
increases by powers of two and finally
the crucial thing is that the way that
two successive spaces are related in the
sequence
is that if a particular function is in
VL and you compress it by a factor of
two then you get off then the function
is going to be in VN minus one okay so
this is by the spaces get smaller and
smaller because they contain the spin
bike and a dilation of the same basis an
interesting thing is that defining the
mult resolution in this way it
essentially is equivalent to giving an
explicit basis to the v l and WL spaces
and that in that sequence so in
particular these axioms are they
essentially but they said they
essentially imply that you can actually
form an orthonormal basis for each of
the VL and WL spaces by just taking a
single special function called the
mother wavelet and another function
called a father wavelet and just looking
at that dilates and translates of these
two functions so this is a very neat
system right where you have an
orthonormal basis for each of these
spaces the spaces are nicely related to
each other these wavelets are related to
each other in this very simple way by
translations and scalings and so so this
this has led to this whole industry of
mostly in the 90s of actually coming up
with such systems which have good
computational properties and nice
analytic properties and so on so in fact
the first such system was actually
describing 100 years ago by har but but
later on the smooth of a blitz were
introduced such as the more let wavelet
hair and then dobisch use famous
wavelets which have come back support
and finite moments and so on so there's
a whole choice of how you actually set
up such a transform which is both
computational attractive so it's easy to
do the fast wavelet transform and has
nice analytic properties ok so the
question is if we have this this nice
well-established theory in harmonic
analysis how much of it transfers to the
discrete case how much of it transfers
to graphs so looking at it this way by
splitting these
these and these are V and W spaces this
idea still very much makes sense on
graphs so there's a clear notion of
smoothness on graphs because there's a
notion of diffusion right that's the
ultimate way of looking at at the birth
ultimate smoothing operator our graph so
something is going to be smooth on the
graph if diffusing a little bit doesn't
change it very much however if diffusing
is little bit kills it or may go totally
changes it then that means that it
should go into the top with you top part
of the space so this business of
recursive is splitting the space of
functions on the graph is very natural
on graphs just as on the real line or
maybe even even more so ok now the
illusion that this basis function should
be localized in both space and frequency
that's again very critical and very not
very natural on a graph this is what I
was alluding to before that if we want
to analyze the relationships with
between people in this room then we
should be able to do it mostly by base
of looking at basis functions which are
localized to people in this room as
opposed to telling us about people
elsewhere in the world ok now what's the
the third property of orthogonal wavelet
transforms namely that you can actually
do this computationally that there's
this basis on each of these spaces and
it's easy to transform from one basis to
another to another to another let's
again a natural criterion and maybe and
that's something that we definitely want
to retain in the graphs case as well
however the trouble is in trying to
define notions of translation and
dilation on the graph because now we are
not on a field right we can't just
multiply can't just multiply the
argument by something to scale and we
can't just translate by subtracting some
multiple of of the stride length and
then the argument of this function right
so this is this is the tricky part how
do we make sense of translating things
on a graph and tan and then and dilating
functions on the graph and actually
actually the
the spectrograph wave learns the ham and
grant van der gang paper that mall road
we didn't to is a very interesting
approach because they say that of course
on the discrete space side we can't
really do that it's the front an idea of
the paper saying that we can't reduce
involved on the on the on in the time
frequency domain but we know exactly how
to do this in the frequency domain so
that's how we are going to define
translation and scaling which is going
to do first a spectral transform going
to do it essentially a Fourier transform
and then and then translate and scale
there and that's how we define our basis
but anyway so that so that's a vibration
the question is how to define an
appropriate mode resolution without an
explicit notion of translation and and
dilation on the graph okay so these are
the general principles of
multiresolution analysis on a discrete
space kind of according to me okay so we
want a sequence of spaces these v spaces
which are a filtration of the space of
functions on x this is a finite space
such as an n-dimensional euclidean space
such that they filter functions
according to smoothness with respect to
this operator okay so this this this
ratio should increase at the other
specific rate at the same time we want
to the these spaces to have a basis or
rather their complements to have the
basis thus wavelet basis which is which
consists of functions that are localized
so you can formalize this this way in
terms of a distance on your on your
space which you certainly have on graphs
or you can just formalize it in terms of
sparsity of these wavelengths and
finally the third criterion is that the
transformations between the subsequent
basis should be should have specific the
sparsity patterns which allows you to
do them efficiently okay so the question
is on a general graph how do we set up a
system which more or less satisfies
these properties and the approach I
advocate in this talk is to change the
whole perspective and view this as a
pure matrix problem so instead of
looking of the forgetting about the fact
that we actually come from a graph just
look at something like the diffusion
operator on the graph regarded as a
matrix and then regard this as just a
matrix factorization issue because
essentially that's what's happening
right so here is your here is your
operator now in matrix form and you look
at you push it through this sequence of
transformations so he's just like basis
changes right the basis changes at the
same time you're reducing the size of
the space of course but let's forget
about that for the moment as a basis
changes literally what's happening is
that you're just multiplying this matrix
on the left and the right by orthogonal
matrices and we want the sparsity
constraint that these orthogonal
matrices are in some sense par so not
just sparse but local so particularly if
these are rotations then they affect
particular like vertices on the graph a
particular sets of coordinates and just
do a local rotation on those and don't
mix with other vertices which are far
away still going into the specific
constraints on the queues and finally
we're going to have the constraint that
that that that these w spaces are split
off so effectively this a matrix is
going to be successively compressed so
these these Q matrices are effectively
going to get smaller and smaller so the
key while i'm not sure if ictal is an
observation because if you because
because it's a fundamental thing but but
it never the connection hasn't isn't
hasn't really been pressed in the
literature the fundamental fact about
our approach is that it makes this very
strong connection between
multiresolution analysis and nate and
multilevel matrix factorizations i'm
going to look at multi relation arises
just as a process of
sing a factorization like this so this
is going to look very much like the you
know numerical linear algebra okay and
here is this pattern of the matrices
getting smaller and smaller again so if
you insist on looking at it as the full
matrices then what happens is that they
just become more and more like that
entity right so the effective size of
the matrix get smaller and smaller so
these rotations are localized two
subsets of the original coordinates of
course they don't have to be the first I
don't know em coordinates that's why I
stuck in this permutation matrix so that
Sammy has to give me the freedom of
figuring out which coordinates I throw
away as wavelets but in terms of a
diagram this is what happens you have
these cue matrices which are smaller and
smaller and they additionally have
sparsity constraints on them ok so our
definition of multi-resolution matrix
factorization is a factorization of this
form we take the matrix and you write it
as this core matrix which is a special
form x these local rotations and that
I'm conjugated by these local rotations
on both sides ok so this this is the
matrix factorization but it's a little
bit more tricky than say an eigen
decomposition you have to specify more
things about it you have to specify
first of all what class of local
rotations these q's come from you have
to specify how many of them you allow to
appear and you have to specify at what
rate the dimensionality decreases so
this is a several degrees of freedom
here which makes this little bit more
tricky and it's a much more general
thing than just but than just their
principal component analysis on the
other hand as we will see it's quite
revealing about the structure of Joe of
the original matrix and it has this
fundamental thing of compressing the
matrix because ultimately what's
happening is that a is compressed into
this form where just a tiny core plus a
whole bunch of things on the diag so if
there's one slide which is key to this
talk then then then it is that is the
slide I want you to bear in your mind
because this is exactly what we're going
to be doing two matrices okay
so since this is a factorization the
question is whether you can do it to
every mater's of course you in general
the answer is no so we have this motion
of multiresolution factorize of all
matrices which can be reduced to this
form over some curly q and over some
sequence of dimensions and so on okay
and I am deciding whether a particular
matrix is in this class or not is a
tricky issue because you have this
combinatorial optimizing the
combinatorial problem in the background
of how to use choose the rotations and
so on so this is not going to be easy to
decide on the other hand in a practical
setting what we want is approximate
matrix factorizations of this form so in
practice there are algorithms are going
to try and come up with a reasonably
good matrix factorization which
encourages little errors as little
reconstruction error as possible now the
thing I haven't told you about is what
these local rotations look like and
they're kind of the simplest thing that
you can imagine in this context so we
looked at two different times one of
them is just a local rotation a cape on
so-called k point rotation which only
involves k coordinates okay suit takes a
coordinates I 12 ik does a k-dimensional
rotation there so it's an element of s
okay and all the other diagonal entries
of the matrix are one or it's a
combination of such k point coordinate k
point rotation so this is what we call
parallel and mf's because they involve
lots of these rotations in parallel so
computationally these things happen in
parallel okay now this thing of course
this is this is one of the standard
buildings of blocks of numerical linear
algebra so in the ke goes to case for
example this is called the Givens
rotation it's just the court rotation of
two coordinates and this is I think
probably the first true numerical linear
algebra algorithm to be invented the
matrix cement for the diagonalization of
symmetric matrices by Jacoby in 1846
just produced one of these
multiresolution matrix factorizations in
terms of Givens rotations except that he
wasn't throwing away coordinates and I
said that he had a well in the limit an
infinitely long list of
of these rotations but we're going to
stop at a certain point so the question
is how do we find this factorization and
as I said instead of really trying to do
for the best one we're going to try and
at least get one which has led to this
small error so error is measured in
terms of reconstruction error which is
the same as the is in a freebie Gnaeus
norm is the difference for meanness norm
difference between the original matrix
and its fourth factorized form and then
we need to optimize this over the choice
of these sets which are there like the
active sets so this is it corresponds to
a choice of which coordinates we throw
away also the form of the final core
matrix and the rotation so the reason
that this is a challenging problem I'm
from monopolization point of view is
because all these things are going on at
the same time and it's a multi-level
problem right so you first decide about
the first level than the second level
that's the first rotation second
rotation and so on and all these levels
in general interact however we might as
well simplified into a sequential
process by treating each level greedily
so this reduces to the problem of
finding the optimal rotation and the
optimal kind of combination of
coordinates at each level so as to kind
of get the matrix as close as possible
well to kind of process the matrix to
come closer to this to this core
diagonal form as much as possible so
currently we are working on so we've got
a deterministic strategy but of course
it's expensive because you need to solve
this combinatorial problem of of a kind
of grouping the different coordinate
we're currently working on the
randomized strategies which would really
make this scale up eventually to
something like complexity of n log n
these slides I'm get you skip over is a
little bit technical they just tell you
that kind of as you would expect what
happens is that you do one of these
rotations and then you figure out which
of the coordinates that you were
involved in the rotation are supposed to
go into the wavelet space and those
coordinates readin get transformed
anymore so
whatever error you incur at that point
whatever you residual you have on that
row or column of the matrix you are
stuck with so this is what makes the
optimization problem viable is that you
can decompose the error level by level
yet so I'm going to skip the actual
formally for these rotations and rather
concentrate on on the conceptual sight
of what's really happening so the
simplest case is when the rotations are
just two dimensional so k equals two and
after each rotation one of the
coordinates becomes a wavelet because
then essentially this induces a tree on
your original coordinates or on your the
vertices of the graph is if you wish so
in terms of the graph language this is
that you take two vertices and you
replace them by as mowers that actually
by an l2 combination of those two
vertices so this is a very simple type
of graph reduction where you take
bunches of vertices and reduce them by
by by by single vertices and effectively
what you get is a hierarchical
clustering think what's interesting is
the higher order case when you do the
whole process more gently so this is the
case for example with third order
rotations where after each rotation the
only throw away one coordinate so
conceptually what this what but what
this really corresponds to whether the
way this this this works is that imagine
that you have a graph which does have
some sort of some sort of more or less
transparent hierarchical structure so it
is it has this sort of clustering
structure that there is a bunch of
vertices here and bunch of vertices here
Monty with is here but these clusters
form a meta cluster and there's another
meta cluster here and here and there so
what's going to happen is that the first
level and an F is going to do a
transformation on these individual
clusters so if Savior there are 10
vertices in this cluster but maybe it's
going to give you but it's going to give
you 10 wavelets which are localized to
the these 10 10 vertices but it's going
to form a distinction between those
wavelets which capture the
local structure within this cluster and
those wavelets which capture the overall
structure of this process so say maybe
six of these wavelets such is going to
be local they go in the W space and you
forgot about them and you're left with
just four wavelets which are then
combined with the four-wheelers from
here and the four-wheelers from here and
so on ok and then you have 12 like
wavelets here but again you do have
another level of MMF and those 12 are
reduced to I don't know two wavelets
describing the global structure of this
meta cluster which are then going to be
combined with a certain number with it
from that the other cluster ok so it
still has this hierarchical feel to it
but you are not making necessarily these
hard assignments right so after one of
these rotations for example so sorry
that the use have been replaced by users
just a older slide then the there is
some of the resulting way that's after
this relation can go into different
places in next level up so it's not just
the tree anymore it's more like a linear
combination of trees and this is why I
say that this less MMF structure is able
to capture more kind of interleaved into
interacting type of hierarchical
structures and graphs not just the
single I or Google clustering ok so so
this is this thing has a number of
applications because it's such a general
way of looking at graphs on such a
general way of looking at matrices so
first of all you have this you find this
higher of yukos spas basis you're also
clustering it also gives the information
about community structure but you can
also turn it around and I should use it
to generate graphs right so if you want
to generate graphs with this love
structure then then then you can use the
algorithm itself to generate graphs for
you which is a separate industry and in
the process of running MMF it compresses
the matrix so just as a compression made
a graph compression of our matrix
compression algorithm it's also I think
of independent interest finally it
provides a basis which you can use for
stuff like lasso and overall the the
structure of
that it finds in the matrix is a as a is
a good starting point for all sorts of
linear algebra operations and solving
the systems of equations and so on
because because once you have this
structure for example multiplying
vectors by matrices in this MMF form is
very fast you just have to perform each
of the each of the Q rotations I one
after the other okay so it's crucial
before I run out of time to emphasize
the connections of this to all the other
things that have come before it which
kind of had a similar flavor so for
example diffusion wavelets right it
starts with the same sort of idea you
start with diffusion and you use it to
compress the graph itself the difference
is that as as Maori set in diffusion
wavelets at least in the in the simplest
numerical implementation of diffusion
whalers instead of forming these Q
rotations independently you really form
them from the individual diffusion
functions on your graph so your thorgan
lies diffusion on the graph essentially
you do a rank revealing QR and that's
what's going to give you your next level
basis and the risk of that its
connections to to the classical
operations and harmonica and as it
notwithstanding is that ranked revealing
QR densified densified your wavelet
elements right so in diffusion start out
nice and local but you have these lots
nice and local functions and you keep
organizing them to each other they
become as you are [ __ ] eyes to more
and more waiters that you have already
removed they become less and less local
they're become more and more dense
whereas in our case we have the explicit
control over the dense the density
pattern of the humate receives ok so
that's the crucial difference between
diffusion wavelets and multiresolution
factorizations now there's also this
thing called tree lots which actually is
just a special case of montrezl elution
factorization so this so so so the
authors of this paper leinad luring
Watson
made an explicit connection just like us
between between Jacobi's method for
matrix factorization and with that
analysis however they really
concentrated on just the 2 by 2 K so the
K equals to K is the Givens rotation
case and the other fundamental
difference was that they were coming
from the statistical angle and they were
really imitating Jacobi's method so the
way instead of solving the optimization
problem that I sketched which was trying
to reduce overall reconstruction error
they were just going up to the largest
of the angle amounts of the matrix of
any one time so did not really a matrix
factorization method the objective
function is not about finding
factorization with small error it's
about something else which is related
but it's still not the same thing and
also it's it they only considered the
gay cause two kids so they were only so
they've really on always had this kind
of hierarchy so it was like a
hierarchical clustering and defining a
basis combined whereas our method is
just like there's a generalization which
is more flexible but I think what's
important to stress is that is that
looking at looking at harmonic analysis
on graphs in this way and looking at
matrix factorization in this way that
allows us to tap into really late rich
literature and applied mathematics
focused around these sort of
hierarchical decomposition ideas which
has been one of the driving forces of
applied math in the last 30 years really
so for example in the realm of partial
differential equations there's this
thing called multigrid where you look at
the problem on different scales and you
solved and then and you can't just solve
it on one scale and refine you need to
propagate errors back and forth between
the different scales but the fundamental
idea is still the same to discretize the
problem at different scales and let the
different scales communicate so to use
locality of the low scales and use
compression at the high scales nnf gives
rise to exactly the same sort of
structures so it's a it's a kind of a
starting point for algebraic multigrid
if you wish if that's the sort of
problem that
you went to solve then there's fast
multiple methods so if you efficiently
want to compute a colonel some of the
colonel between a large number of
particles the way you do it is that you
claw hierarchical faster the particles
and say that the effect of nearby
particles in a particular particle here
you need to take individual particles
into account but if something is further
away then you can just look at the
aggregate effect of the whole cluster so
this is a game very similar to how nmf
have hierarchically clusters the
dimensions and reduces and kind of
compresses the problem and finally
explicitly in the world of of numerical
linear algebra but largely motivated by
these bde applications there's a whole
bunch of different major decomposition
methods of increasing complexity like H
matrices so the here I are matrices and
h 2 matrices and hierarchies any sim
simple matrices which combine similar
ideas of blog diagonal matrices and then
doing rotations and then blog
diagonalizing again but it's not quite
the same so it's more like making a
connection to these ideas rather than
just plugging in one of these one of
these established things and applied
math ok so finally we also did some we
also tried to to find the deeper
connections to to the theory of harmonic
analysis so how do we know that what we
get out of this is really a wavelet
process it's localized then it has
something to do with the limit with the
smoothing operator on our space but is
it does it really qualify as a wavelet
so this is something that sometimes
keeps me up at night but there are
standard tests for that and one of them
is this whole the criterion which
essentially says that if you have a
function which is which is smooth in the
sense that doesn't change much between
points which are close together in the
metric of the original space then the
high-frequency way that components are
supposed to be small
and usually this criterion is formatted
in the context of what is called spaces
of homogeneous type so you can have a
harmonic analysis which is going to obey
this sort of criteria as long as the
underlying space is somehow nicely
behaved we're home space of homogeneous
type roughly corresponds to the fact
that there is some loose notion of local
dimensionalities as you grow balls the
volume of the blue balls approximately
grows with some power of the radius and
the question is what are the analogs of
this on a graph or a matrix so what we
came up with this is a little bit too
technical to youth parson the remaining
ninety seconds was a slightly more
complicated notion of homogeneity
related to taking sub matrices
essentially forming graphs from sub
matrices of the original matrix and then
looking at the eigenvalues and bounding
the eigenvalues of the normalized
laplace normalized adjacency matrix away
from both 0 and 1 so this says something
like you know the the bruise and columns
in the sub matrix are neither two
orthogonal new nor two parallel so this
sort of thing is satisfied then in fact
we can come up with the holotype
criteria for the decay of these way that
coefficients so there is a connection to
to to the classical theory normal
classes but I really want to understand
it better and finally so we tried it out
at the moment of experimental evaluation
is a little bit limited because these
ideas are fairly new still and i haven't
scaled it up to running hit on matrices
of size or a hundred thousand or a
million vertices and sod but we tried it
out on these standard small things and
we kind of see what you would expect
that if the underlying thing does have a
hierarchical structure then we do well
and we do better than competing methods
such as tree let's write so this is the
tiny thing of I think this
The Karate Club draft and and and this
is this is a this is a graph taken from
from genetics and we see that we see
that we do better than treat it's in
particular of the natural competitors in
such a special case of our method is not
entirely surprising because we optimized
for reconstruction error where
streetlights does something else okay
but on a slightly and we also saw that
we also try that on on the graphs which
have is very rigid structure so one
attempt to produce graphs with a
hierarchical structure and a
fractal-like structure is the kronecker
product graphs so reconstructing that
we're really good at that because
essentially we go after the same sort of
structure so where's nyström methods
which randomly sample rows and columns
from the matrix don't do super so well
we get a really small error on the other
hand at the opposite extreme when the
matrix is random so there is no
hierarchical structure then we don't do
well at all whereas nystrom can do
better so as a first shot expect
experimentally evaluating this method I
was pushing this compression case
because it's such a such a crucial issue
and in machine learning problems at the
moment just how to take large matrices
large colonel matrices for example and
compress them to make them more
manageable and often that arises in the
context of graphs so kernels on graphs
or graphs like things like like your
grand matrices then used by their
Gaussian kernel and and we find that
compared to this fairly standard
methodology of taking random rows and
columns we in fact do better now there
are two caveats rail or first of all we
retain more information right because we
factorize the matrix into this core
diagonal part so there is a core which
is equivalent or analogous to what the
nystrom methods do but also we have
these diagonal components there's more
information there but computationally it
doesn't come at an added expense because
typically what you want the reason you
want to compress in the first
is to do something like invert the
matrix and the diagonal matrix is very
easy to invert the other thing is that
this is still the version of the
algorithm which does the exact matching
at each level so in fact computing the
factorization is fairly expensive there
are new wall clock times reported here
but on that river front we would not be
doing so well but the randomized version
i think is pretty as long as the
structures there it's pretty natural to
come up with a randomized video which is
going to make this scale well with the
size of the matrices okay so let me just
summarize this is the this is the last
si so so this multi-resolution
factorization is a new type of matrix
factorization which has more complicated
structure than classical factorizations
but it is more revealing about the
structure of the underlying matrix or
the underlying graph if the matrix is
actually the adjacency matrix or the
diffusion matrix on the graph so in some
sense it's leads to this generalization
of rat instead of looking at a global I
began factors we are extracting
structure at multiple different scales
and in terms of sig analogy to topic
models this would be an interesting
comparison whether the actual wavelet we
find similar to to the diffusion rivers
case make sense in terms of the
semantics of the underlying problem ok
so NLF exploits hierarchy but does not
inform a single does not enforce a
single hierarchy so it's not just a
higher clustering and then something top
on top of that it can capture these
intersecting hierarchies yeah now this
is a bit of an exaggeration given that
we've done on a week or two are words of
experiments but it seems like at least
in many and then various view for these
test examples for compressing matrices
many of actually does really well ok now
regarding the algorithmic side of
everything every day d ln f is a
fundamental local operation so all the
rotations are local all the
optimizations with you are local so as
long as we can find nearest neighbor
essentially nearest neighbors and this
matrix fast and we can update this gift
table of nearest neighbors fast that NN
f
should be at least empirically it should
be an algorithm with scales with order n
or for the n log n it's eventually
computing the factorization ok and once
you have the factorization it's going to
be a building block for various medical
linear algebra operations so once you
know that your matrix is of this very
structured form then you can multiply
such matrices by vectors easily you can
invert such matrices and you can even do
more ambitious things like actually run
something like mill multigrid on a
matrix of this form and n enough to kind
of taps into all these different
communities right so there are clear
connections to diffusion wavelets and
Cree let's also things like multiscale
SVD decompositions that have come up in
machine learning but it also taps into
this world of structured matrices and
algebraic multigrid and fast multiple
methods and the whole bunch of other
thing on other ways in which people have
tried to extract hierarchy from problems
in applied math and exploit it somehow
but somehow in the world of data this
has not been this is still a a
relatively relatively small stream of
research is but ultimately as you know
we're in an age where the amount of data
is growing at an intimidating rate and
at the same time parallelism is the only
way that we can we can process that data
so this so some sort of hierarchical
approaches which can exploit locality
and data is ultimately going to be the
only way that we're going to be able to
move forward and look at larger problems
so maybe MMF with that
yes okay so i can ask you something like
in the simplest case where k is but does
it like the way you find all those cues
does it reduce to exactly how regular
posturing where are you bad all the
license plates well it depends on which
type of higher the list ring is that the
question is you know how do you find
which to which two coordinates to join
and then yeah that's actually my
question right how do i compute if they
understand the QC finding which that the
sequence of use are they allergy in some
ways they are merging points but they
are not merging with about they're
merging points explicitly so as to
minimize this residual or reconstruction
error which is not the same as an
hierarchical clustering and also when
you're merging points but how do you
merge points right so do some one way
you can merge points of view have two
points and you can repeat youth of you
replace them by the average or do you
replace them by by something else in
winning between them we have multiple
points and you replace them by the
median or something here we take in this
rotation so it's like it's the average
in the AL to sounds actually bit similar
to to diffusion waivers so that's a very
specific way of reducing the graph and
it's not typically how people were
pp-people do
question
read the Kraken top line Oh